an approximation to the statement. There are different
notions of approximation that one might be interested in
and we'll see a couple
of them in the third unit of the series, but for these different
notions of approximation,
there are quantitative statements
of the no-cloning theorem that put strong limits on how well you can approximately clone.
A second remark is that copying or cloning standard basis states most
certainly is possible.
For example, a Controlled NOT gate copies the standard basis states of a Qubit.
This doesn't contradict
the no-cloning theorem. The point is that cloning in the sense of the no-cloning theorem requires
that this works not only
for standard basis states
but for all states.
A Controlled NOT gate
certainly doesn't clone a plus state for instance.
And finally, it is worth pointing out that there's also a no-cloning theorem for
probabilistic states.
It's just not something
that people talk about or care about.
If somebody randomly
chooses a bit, for instance, for some arbitrary way of
assigning probabilities to the two values and
then hands you that bit,
of course there's no way for you to obtain two independent samples
of that random bit.
You just don't know what
the probabilities are.
You can copy the bit just like a Controlled NOT
copies standard basis states, but that's not the same thing as cloning the probabilistic state.
You just don't have enough
information to do that. Whatever random bit you were given doesn't tell you what
the probabilities were.
It's just a bit.
The impossibility of cloning
a probabilistic state follows from exactly the same reasoning as in the quantum setting.
Cloning is a non-linear process, whereas probabilistic operations, just like unitary operations, are linear.
Anyway, it's not surprising
that we can't clone on a probabilistic state and
somehow it's not as interesting as the fact that we can't
clone a quantum state,
but the point is simply to observe that this is not a uniquely
quantum phenomenon.
The final limitation
of quantum information that we'll discuss in this lesson is that it's not possible
to perfectly discriminate
two quantum states that aren't orthogonal.
Another way of saying this
is that if two quantum states can be perfectly discriminated, then they have to be orthogonal.
What we mean when we refer
to a perfect discrimination of two quantum states, Psi and Phi, is that there's some
way to tell them apart
without any chance of error.
In terms of the quantum circuit model, we can express this as you
see here on the screen.
We have some unitary operation U, which could be implemented
as a quantum circuit or we could just think about U abstractly
as a unitary operation
and force input U takes either the state Psi or the state Phi
along with a bunch of initialized Qubits, which you can think of as workspace Qubits that somehow assist in this
process of discrimination.
After U as applied, the top Qubit is measured with respect to a standard basis measurement and here's the perfect
discrimination part.
If the input state was Psi, then the measurement must
give the outcome zero, 100% of the time, and if
the input state was Phi,
then the measurement must
give the outcome one, again with 100% chance.
It's not important what the
states of these other Qubits are after U was applied.
All that matters is this one bit that we get from the measurement because that's the bit that's telling us which of the two states we started with.
For some choices of states, Psi and Phi, it will be possible to perform a perfect discrimination like
this and for others it won't.
And what we'll observe is that
if it is possible to do this, then Psi and Phi have
to be orthogonal states
and that means if Phi and
Psi are not orthogonal, you can't perfectly discriminate them.
So let's see why a perfect discrimination implies orthogonality.
We'll start by writing down two equations that express what these
two diagrams express.
If we think about the quantum state, we get after applying U to a
bunch of initialized Qubits together with the state Psi,
we see that it has to
have this form right here, where Pi zero is some quantum state vector representing the state
of all of these Qubits
except for the top one. We don't have any information
about this quantum state, Pi zero, it could be anything,
but we know that the entire
state has to look like this because that's the only
way that the measurement is guaranteed to give the
outcome zero, 100% of the time.
And we have an analogous
equation for the second one.
This time the top Qubit
has to be in the one state and similar to Pi zero, the
state Pi one could be anything.
And in addition to having
no information about Pi one, we also don't know anything
about the relationship between Pi zero and Pi one.
For all we know, these are just two
arbitrary quantum states.